well front and center in the news cycle
right now
100 million Capital One customers were
hacked everything you need to know about
data breaches but we're afraid acts can
ask a Capital One finance Corp announced
late Monday that more than 100 million
people had had their personal
information act the hacker got
information including credit score's
balances zip codes email addresses dates
of birth self-reported income payments
histories fragments of transaction data
and the social security numbers of about
a hundred and forty thousand customers
at about eighty thousand bank account
numbers from credit card customers I
Bank said will offer free credit
monitoring services to those affected
consumers and small businesses who
applied for credit cards from 2005
through 2019 or most at risk the hack
affected about 100 million people in the
US the company couldn't say for sure
whether the data leaked to his used for
fraud but said it was unlikely first
heard about the hack on July 19 waited
until July 29 to inform customers as it
sought out from law enforcement to catch
the alleged perpetrator which has been
done by the way Capital One's offered
$125 to anyone whose data was hacked or
free credit monitoring for ten years our
privacy experts say credit monitoring
only looks for changes on the credit
report indicating that someone is using
your personal information to open new
accounts in your name but it does not
prevent someone from taking it alone in
your name such security precautions are
unlikely to help people protect against
a hack like the one Capital One
announced Monday exposure of data that
can't be changed such as social security
numbers are the hallmarks of a
particularly severe data breach so we've
got an inside source at the ad agency
for Capital One and you know their
slogan is what's in your wallet they're
going to change it too we want to let
know what's in your wallet or possibly
we could be the side a bar another one
they're experimenting with they're gonna
focus group this what's in your wallet
oh wait everyone already knows that's
another possible slogan for them they
could change it to that fun picking on
Capital One they're an easy target to
pick on so by the way let me head let
you know how much of my data they got
none because I don't do business with
people like Capital One to start with
and I certainly wasn't applying for a
small business loan or credit card
people like Capital One to start with
and if you've been listening to me you
wouldn't either so you would have been
vulnerable to putting up with this crap
oh wait we already know what's in your
wallet so this article has a couple of
good points so it says check your
accounts check to see if your accounts
have been affected if you are a Capital
One customer and know the difference
between a credit freeze and a lock a
freeze means a consumer cannot take out
a new loan or a credit card without
unfreezing the report first it also
prevents a hacker from taking out a loan
in your name false it only prevents a
hacker from taking out a loan in your
name
if the lending institution checks your
credit only to intend credit card
applications actually have the credit
checked they issue them to dead people
and dogs eight out of ten times if
you're breathing or not or if it's you
or not or if it's a shredded application
tape back together or not they will
issue the card eight out of ten times
without checking and freezing will not
help you with that
mine's frozen to my account has been
frozen which has a big zero on it anyway
but that's my credit score is zero I
don't have a credit score because I
don't know FICO I don't worship at the
altar of the great FICO Oh FICO you are
our provider thank you great FICO no we
don't do that stuff here so anyway the
only that problem but everything's
frozen but it still doesn't keep you
from someone from opening a loan only if
the credit institution making the loan
is smart enough to actually do a credit
check and they don't always do that
kinda seems like common sense but they
don't
number-three sign up for an additional
fraud protection which we do recommend
we've always recommended Xander
insurances identity theft protection I
carry it on me I carry it on all my
family all my home I
team here have got it as a employee
benefit and what the difference is and
what they said is correct earlier in the
article indicating you know credit
monitoring doesn't help because they can
take out a loan all credit monitoring
does this go
oh we're monitoring the fact that you
just got your identity stolen and that's
all it shows up at least tells you so
you can go do something about it the
better
ID theft protection companies like
Zander assign a caseworker to the
problem to help you go fix it and get
rid of all the crap out of your life
which $125 won't even touch the hassle
see you're not liable if someone opens
an account in your name fraudulently
because it's not you that did it but you
have to go prove six ways from Sunday
that it wasn't you and so there's police
reports and affidavits and notarized
documents and all this garbage you have
to go through and it's a you know you'll
lose 600 hours on an identity theft 600
hours getting there to getting your life
back if your identity gets stolen like
this so I'm you know go ahead and get
with Zander insurance and get this stuff
in place so someone else does all that
work because it's just a matter of time
before someone has your numbers you
don't have to do business with a company
like Capital One to get your number
stolen I mean it's there's been hundreds
and hundreds and hundreds of millions of
these things know the difference between
a hack and a breach a breach is when a
company doesn't really matter much on
that I don't know why you don't even
know the difference but a breach is just
when there's a vulnerability and the the
you know we left the door open but
nobody stole anything you know a hack is
where a you know a robber kicked in the
door went in took all your stuff okay
that's a hack and this girl I read a
couple articles about this girl that was
the hacker I don't know anything about
it another one I read about this morning
when I saw a page something she used to
work for him is on Web Services which
they're having a happy day now knowing
that their former employee is a cyber a
domestic cyber terrorist because let me
just tell you when you do this it costs
people regular people and companies this
is at least a hundred million dollar
theft
and everybody's acting like oh she
thinks she's an anarchist let me tell
you what I think she is she's a freaking
criminal that I'll be put under the jail
and not be let out for food she's not an
anarchist
she's a cyber terrorist a domestic cyber
terrorist it's not cute you're from
Seattle it's not funny
you're not vogue you're not cutting-edge
progressive you're not resistance you're
a criminal a world-class criminal the
FBI came to your house criminal go to
jail do not pass go do not collect $200
criminal this is not cute it's a hundred
million dollar minimum expense that she
has extracted on society because she's
pissed off at the world and has some
skills put her in jail so that we can
let the rest these cutesy little hacker
butts that think they can do this crap
get away with it put her in jail she's a
criminal was that unclear I sure hope
not
Capital One what's in your wallet
oh wait everyone already knows